[Music]
what's going on guys you know they're
good movies bad movies and movies that
are so bad
they're good there's no better example
of that than the movie the room written
by directed and starring the Enigma that
is Tommy Weis oh did not hit her I did
not
oh hi Mark James Franco directed and
stars in the new movie disaster artist
about the making of the room
I did not oh hi mark I had the chance to
sit down with him and some of the casts
to talk about some of our favorite so
bad they're good movies check this out
fellas Congrats on making just a super
entertaining funny movie and I came up
with a couple of guilty pleasure movies
I'd love for you guys to read these
lines as Tommy and Greg showgirls well
rice and vegetables so my Greg Boyce is
essentially my voice do you like brown
rice and vegetables yeah you do really
love I just love doggy chow - aha
fantastic yeah I might just do all my
movies as Tommy then I think you should
I have some wines from some of my
favorites so bad it's good movies um if
you guys wouldn't mind just like giving
us some reads okay you know what happens
when the toad gets struck by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else yeah twister from x-men
yes door
to a toad when it's struck by lightning
the same thing that happens to
everything else
this is katana she's got my back
I would advise not getting killed by her
her sword traps the souls of its victims
another from the American classic
Suicide Squad yeah I'm advised not
getting killed by her I don't like sand
it's coarse and rough and irritating and
it gets everywhere that was a better
read than my words - why is the one
give it up you'll never find her if
you're not telling me all her people
stop don't do it the people you make an
amazing villain ya always told him
yeah but he's I'm now a villain a hero I
could see you as Dracula Frankenstein ah
Frankenstein I'm a hero
do you think he's a vampire in real life
the accent
am i hearing an accent oh no no we're
doing the green-screen not wanting to
shoot outside there was at one point a
storyline that he was entertaining for
the room where maybe Johnny vampire and
he drives into his convertible off roof
and flying this guy I don't know just
idea brilliant idea I'm gonna take you
to the bank senator Trent the blood bank
that is Steven Seagal at hard to kill
cars boards bikes I like anything fast
enough to do something stupid in is that
xxx I watched the second xxx movie it's
so funny then clearly more than he
thinks if you were like Vin Diesel
described Xander cage the first word he
would say is
once again about john mcleaney a New
Jersey sense of humor no I live my life
a quarter mile at a time
nothing else matters pop the mortgage
bubble support cannot buy tea but their
[ __ ] for those 10 seconds or less
I'm free
it's a now but you got to pay the
mortgage
fellas Congrats on the movie and thanks
taking the time thanks Lou yeah uh that
was a good time
so where are some of your favorites so
bad they're good movies what are some of
the most quotable lines let us know in
the comments section below we want to
know I want to thank you brought in
screen junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up
on Twitter by bike